some 10 billion dollars of afghanistan's
money remains out of reach for the
taliban because the united states won't
allow it the white house has said the
reserves which are held in the u.s can't
be released due to legal reasons and
because the group is listed as a terror
organization
while that is true it is also true that
half of afghanistan's population is
facing hunger and people don't have
access to cash aid agencies like the
world food programme have repeatedly
asked for money to help afghans but the
question occupying many governments is
this
how do you help afghans without
inadvertently legitimizing or
financially helping the taliban
this hospital in the province of bamiyan
provides a stark reminder of the crisis
unfolding in afghanistan and also the
dilemma facing the international
community
more and more children are being
admitted here because they do not have
enough to eat
the un has warned that 55 percent of the
population are facing extreme levels of
hunger and that thousands could die this
winter
yet money that could be used to
alleviate the suffering there is frozen
in the united states
and there appears to be no chance of
that changing in the near future
the united states continues to face
difficult fundamental questions about
how it might be able to make reserve
funds available to directly benefit the
people of afghanistan with while
ensuring that the funds do not benefit
the taliban
when the taliban took power in august
washington blocked access to nearly 10
billion dollars in afghanistan's central
bank reserves held in the u.s
other institutions such as the imf also
stopped disbursing aid to the country
citing a lack of clarity about the
legitimacy of the new taliban-led
government in a rare interview the
afghan foreign minister pleaded with the
u.s to change its position
he said despite stripping women of their
rights and accusations that the taliban
summarily executes its opponents his
government can and should be trusted
making afghanistan unstable or having a
weak afghan government is not in the
interest of anyone it will not benefit
anyone
we are trying to have an afghanistan
which is not in conflict with anyone and
would stand on its own two feet in the
future
more humanitarian aid does appear to be
on its way and not just this offering
from china after the world bank said it
would transfer money directly to aid
organizations such as the world food
programme and unicef
but while aware of the urgent needs
facing afghanistan the u.s points out
that the taliban is a designated global
terrorist group and that this makes the
issue of releasing funds to them both
challenging
and complicated
and joining me now for more is
journalist ali latifi who has reported
on
afghanistan and from afghanistan for
years and now is in doha ali it's clear
afghans need help should the u.s release
the nearly 10 billion dollars in afghan
reserves it holds
well you know this what people keep
saying is that these reserves you know
this this money that it um
adds up to it belongs to the avalon
people so it's not really up to the
united states to decide what to do with
that you know yes it's being stored in
the federal reserve but
that doesn't mean that they should be
able to withhold it from the avalon
people who now more than ever really
really need it you know because they're
facing
a massive hunger crisis you know the the
value of the honey has dropped
precipitously
there's no employment there's no work
banks aren't able to function properly
so what a lot of people are saying is
that
you know it's not really up to yes it's
being housed in the united states but
it's not really necessarily up to the
united states who gets this money when
why or how i suppose the main question
that the us government and other
governments are facing at the moment is
how do you help afghans without
legitimizing or inadvertently
financially helping the taliban i mean
how does one do this
i mean
this is the issue that it's been five
months that they haven't been able to
answer this question yet you know they
haven't come up with a solution they
keep saying no no no no
or they keep adding new sort of um
demands or or restrictions to it you
know only if you meet these sorts of um
demands will we you know release the
funds but what they're not doing is in
the meantime figuring out a way to make
it work
you know it's been five months they
still haven't actually figured out some
kind of a mechanism to get money to
people that are in need uh without
quote-unquote legitimizing the taliban
and yet at the same time you know their
officials their leaders are coming to
kabul and meeting with them or are
meeting with them in doha so
you know to a lot of people in
afghanistan it's really strange because
it's like on the one hand you say you
don't want to legitimize them but then
on the other you're actually sitting
down with them and you're considering
reopening your embassies and you know
you are still sending some level of
money in so what is
you know what what is left to keep the
actual money that the avalon people need
back into the country to get it back in
let's take this a step forward and let's
look at it from the point of view of the
taliban i mean is there a case you think
for the taliban to be actually trusted
to help afghans get back on their feet
something that could potentially be in
the taliban's best interests and if this
indeed were the case then maybe a case
for
releasing money to afghanistan and by
extension the taliban
it's definitely in the taliban's best
interest because if they can pull it off
then they show look we were the ones to
save the avalon people right the former
governor government ran away
the us and the eu and all these other
countries you know they they cut off
their funding and then when they gave it
back to and in that amount of time
people were literally starving you know
people were selling their kidneys people
were selling their organs to make money
and now you know now that they've given
us the money again
we're able to distribute it and we're
able to keep people from being hungry
that's if they can pull it off now
that's a huge if
um because they haven't really shown
that you know they know how to govern
that they know how to provide services
that they know how to lead a government
they haven't shown any of those things
but the one thing that they will say is
that we're not corrupt like the former
government you know and that to them is
a big big selling point because
if you think about it at this point in
these last five six months there's
almost nobody that's saying oh if only
the former government came back came
back to power people were upset with
them people were fed up with the
corruption and the fraud and the lies
and everything that came from that
government
but
the taliban has not yet shown that they
can be trustworthy so it is a big test
for them and if they can pull it off
then yeah then they win because they say
look we're not as fraudulent as the
former government and when you gave us
that money we were actually able to
provide it to the people in need um
so now it's it's it's an issue of trust
on on the foreigner side and it's an
issue of the taliban actually being able
to carry out you know that that burden
that will be placed upon them to make
sure that it actually re reaches the
people that really really need it
it's not the last conversation we'll
have about this but we'll have to leave
it there for the time being ali latif in
doha thank you so much for joining us
today
thank you
you